captain well a great many people see you  as a hero there are some would prefer  the word vigilante you've operated with  unlimited power and no supervision  that's something the world can no longer  tolerate  I know how much Bucky means you stay out  of this one please you saying you'll  arrest me there will be consequences  captain you seem a little defensive buzz  been a long day  if you can accept limitations we're not  better in the bad guys that's not the  way I see  sometimes I want to punch you in your  perfect teeth  what do we do we fight  you know what's about to happen  want to punch your way out of this  sorry tally you know I wouldn't do this  fight any other choice but he's my  friend so was I been feeling a hundred  knives hidden half tons in potassium is  a [ __ ] and rods zips just eats the harm  it wouldn't against them